caught on camera not for the first time
the Home Secretary arriving at a London
charity this morning found to be
speeding last summer swella bravaman is
accused of asking civil servants to help
arrange a private speed awareness course
I was speeding I regret that I paid the
fine and I took the points but we're
focused now on delivering for the
British people and working for them did
you ask civil servants to put you on a
one-on-one speed increase in relation to
the process I'm focused on delivering
for the British people do my job at home
safely then what I will say is that in
my view I'm confident that nothing
untoward has happened are you going to
resign Home Secretary
trying to focus on the day job it's
ultimately for the prime minister to
decide whether his ethics advisor opens
an investigation into the Home Secretary
that would likely Center on this part of
the government rule book that states
ministers should uphold the political
impartiality of the Civil Service I've
always been clear that where issues like
this are raised they should be dealt
with properly and they should be dealt
with professionally since I've returned
from the G7 I have been receiving
information on the issues raised I have
met with both the independent advisor
and the Home Secretary I've asked for
further information and I'll update the
on the appropriate course of action in
due course at the home office this row
comes at a tense time with new migration
data this week set to show another big
rise the context of this speeding story
is arguably as important as the
allegations so Ella bravman has been
pushing for tougher measures to curb
migration with some suggestions running
into resistance from other members of
the cabinet she's also ruffled feathers
after giving a speech at a right-wing
conference last week that some felt
sounded a little too much like a
leadership pitch
in the Commons labor accusing the prime
minister of being in Hawk to his party
and unable to act the prime minister is
clearly too weak to sort this out well
if the Home Secretary cannot get a grip
or
rule-breaking Behavior how can she get a
grip on anything else Home Secretary
accusing labor of playing politics they
want to talk about
talk about drafts
from the fact that they voted against
tougher sentences for pedophiles and
murderers they want us to ignore the
fact that labor MPS would rather
campaign to stop the deportation of
foreign criminals than back arawanda
scheme we welcome you in the message
often polarizing some allies of the Home
Secretary do claim the speeding story is
an attempt to discredit her over
migration it's now for Rishi sunak to
decide how to proceed a minister with
friends and foes making the way forward
particularly fraught Rob Powell Sky News
in Westminster